Ok, so, all gripes against Spider-Man 3 aside,
we still love Sam Raimi's trilogy for its
heartfelt take on the amazing wall-crawler.
The studio basically made him shoehorn Venom
into the third movie, overruling his wishes
to make Sandman its only villain and ruining
the chances for Spider-Man 4.
But thanks to some concept art by storyboard
artist Jeffrey Henderson, we can see that
Spidey would've taken on the Vulture and Mysterio...if
Raimi had managed to hang around for a fourth
movie, that is.
Busting Mysterio
The storyboard concept art for Mysterio doesn't
really show a fight between him and Spidey,
but we can imagine how great it might have
been. Mysterio mainly uses special effects,
illusions, hypnotism, and theatrics, so he
may not have been too serious of a threat
compared to the rest of Spider-Man's foes.
That unmasked Mysterio at the police station
looks...kind of like Bruce Campbell, right?
Given Raimi's longtime friendship with Campbell,
it would've been the perfect casting. The
Evil Dead star appeared in all three Spider-Man
movies that Raimi directed.
First he was the announcer who named Peter
Parker "Spider-Man."
Then he was the snooty theater usher in the
sequel.
And he finally played the French restaurant
maître d' in Spider-Man 3.
We can almost imagine Mysterio's backstory
just based on Campbell's three appearances
in the previous Spider-Man films. He wanted
to get into show business, but had to settle
as a lowly wrestling announcer. Then he tried
to work in theater, but never made it. As
a result, he became an usher. But when that
didn't work out, he ultimately resorted to
a restaurant gig where he used his acting
skills to fake a French accent.
In a bind for cash, he stole a bunch of special
effects equipment for a robbery, becoming
Mysterio—only to be busted by Spider-Man.
How great would it have been to see Maguire
and Campbell facing off one last time?
The Vulture takes flight
These storyboard scenes of the Vulture seem
a lot more serious in tone than Mysterio's,
suggesting that he may have been the movie's
main villain.
You can see him reaching for a helicopter
and taking on Spider-Man in the skies above
New York.
And it looks like the Vulture's suit is very
much in sync with the character's original
comic book outfit. This is pretty different
from the first villain of the Spidey movies,
Willem Dafoe's Green Goblin, who has a modernized
look compared to the source material.
Well, what do you think? Would a fourth movie
have righted the wrongs of Spider-Man 3? Or
would the Vulture and Mysterio have been the
final fall for Tobey Maguire's Spider-Man?
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know who you think should've played Spider-Man
4's villains...